JUDY SINGER: I'm Judy Singer.
I'm the Senior Vice Provost
for Faculty Development
and Diversity and I want to
welcome you all to this event
on how to write
an Op-Ed, getting
your voice into the news media.
I want to just make
a few framing remarks
before turning it over to the
moderator of this panel, Ann
Marie Lipinski.
And in thinking about how
to help the faculty get
their voice out into the world,
we've done a number of events
and this one happens to be the
second time we've done this--
it's particularly popular.
And when we planned
this event, we
were thinking that there are
people on the faculty who
are interested in
figuring out how
to reach a broader audience.
But I think the events
of the last month
have really called to task the
need for people in academia,
now more than ever, to
get their voices out,
regardless of where
they fall in the debate.
I think there's
just a need for us
to take the time that we
have spent in dedicating
our lives to the study
of particular subjects
to think about speaking, not
just to our colleagues, which
is what we do as our
bread and butter,
but to a broader audience.
And people in the room
have a lot to offer.
I'm particularly
pleased with the breadth
of people who are here.
We have people from various
different schools at Harvard,
various different disciplines.
We run the gamut
from, oftentimes,
we get arts and humanities and
social science people here.
We have science people, law,
business, public health--
range of fields--
and I think that's,
actually, terrific
because it represents the riches
that Harvard has to offer,
but also the kinds of voices
that the folks who are up here
are interested in hearing
from because you might not
meet some of these
people in the course
of your everyday business.
The Op-Ed forum is
particularly interesting
because it's a short form.
We're used to writing
in longer form
and I think one of
the things that you'll
hear from the panelists
is how to help
think about moving
from the long form
that we're comfortable
being with whether it's
an article which you don't
think of as a long form,
but to these people,
that's a long form,
or even teaching a
class or a seminar
where you've got
an hour, two hours,
three hours to give your views
versus 90 seconds on the radio.
So the short form, I think,
is particularly attractive
and in thinking about how to
take the work that we produce
and make it more
accessible to people,
but also for people
who are writing a book,
one of my first pieces of
advice is why don't you
start with an Op-Ed because a
book is a very long commitment
and an Op-Ed is something
that's much more achievable
and I think that's some
of what you'll hear today.
The third part of
thinking about this event
is that it's actually quite
instrumental in nature.
Our panelists are very
interested in establishing
relationships with
members of our faculty
who do have something to
say about issues of the day
or other kinds of topics that
would have a broader audience.
And I'm going to
end with an anecdote
that at the end of the event
that we did two years ago,
one of the people in the room,
who was a first year assistant
professor, went up
to Trish Hall who
was Jim Dao's predecessor
at the New York Times
and pitched an idea.
And three weeks later,
she had the lead Op-Ed
in the New York Times.
So that gave me great pleasure
to see the kind of instrumental
nature of that.
So I'm hoping for a
repeat and maybe a repeat
across some other news outlets.
So with those
framing remarks, I am
going to turn the
moderator role over
to Ann Marie Lipinski who
is the curator of the Nieman
Foundation for Journalism, which
is here at Harvard University.
It's a wonderful resource that
we have here and, in fact,
there are lots of
journalists at Nieman
who potentially could
also be helpful as you're
thinking about this role.
She also, before
she came to Harvard,
was the editor in chief
of the Chicago Tribune
and is a Pulitzer
Prize winner herself.
So she has been both
in the publishing end
and also now with
many years here
at Harvard and time as also
with the University of Chicago,
also understands
the academic end
and I think it's
in a great position
to bridge these two worlds.
So let me turn it
over to Ann Marie.
ANN MARIE LIPINSKI:
Thank you so much, Judy.
Judy has very happily
made me her co-conspirator
on a couple of initiatives here
at Harvard bringing faculty
and journalists together.
And I am always
delighted to play
that role for her and with her.
So thank you for giving me the
chance to do that again today.
When she first reached out to
me to see if this was possible
today, it was many months
before the election.
And I think, certainly, my
views and maybe your views
of the value or lack thereof of
opinion journalism or opinion
writing have maybe changed some.
But I want to make sure--
so Op-Ed-- the term comes
from opposite editorials.
Right?
That's what it
means, but I think
the op is often misused
to just focus on opinion.
It's also the first two
letters of that word.
And I think what you'll find
with the group of people
we are talking with today,
the world is awash in opinion
and you can publish
it anywhere you want.
You can publish your columns
on medium, you can publish,
you can tweet, you can
post them on Facebook,
you probably are members
of small Facebook groups
or Google Groups
or Google Hangouts
or any number of select cohorts
you make yourself a part of
and you can talk with them and
share your opinions with them
at ease.
The difference between that
and what our colleagues today
are going to talk
about is really
reaching an audience outside
of that bubble and the accent
not necessarily on opinion,
but on information,
on expertise, and on
sharing that expertise
in a sophisticated
way with a broader
audience than, perhaps, many
of you are used to speaking to
or with.
And the value to us as
journalists is tremendous.
The ability of somebody with
an expertise about a subject
to be able to express that
to people beyond their ken
is incredibly valuable
in a democracy and just
to us individually
as people who are
very interested in
your work, but maybe
can't always understand it.
And so I think there's sometimes
this divide between what
journalism does and
what the academy does
and, hopefully, at the end
of our time here together,
that will be demystified for you
and also some for our panelists
whose backgrounds,
with one exception,
are on the journalism side.
As Judy said, we saw this become
very successful the first time
she hosted such a conversation
and, hopefully, that
will be the same for today.
So I was, yesterday
and today, just
looking at kind of recent
examples of the kinds of things
that our three journalists
here today think
about or have chosen as opinion
pieces or Op-Ed pieces to use.
And so James, in
the last day or so,
has overseen the publication
of a piece in the New York
Times written by a Cuban
born American who's
writing about her reactions
to Castro's death and the kind
of haunting presence
he had in her life
really from the time
she was cognizant.
A freshmen from New
York University writing
about the animosity that--
I'm not sure if
it's a he or she,
there were initials
only in the piece--
JAMES DAO: It's a she.
ANN MARIE LIPINSKI: She-- that
she has experienced as somebody
who is a Trump supporter.
A piece about how
the FCC is going
to auction off a chunk of the
public airwaves and an argument
that the writer makes for using
the proceeds from that to build
a 21st century infrastructure
of public interest media
written by the president
of a foundation.
In the Globe "Ideas"
section, there
was a piece about
our complicated views
about nature and how we think
about alien species invading
our habitats, and
examination of the labor
movement in the age of Trump.
We've all certainly
heard the term Alt-Right.
I've not heard
the term Alt-Labor
so I learned about
Alt-Labor through that piece
and it's a new approach
to pro-worker activism.
And over a cognoscente
at WBUR, there
was a piece about speaking up
for undocumented workers who
you may work with yourself.
And also, one that was
very relevant to many of us
last week, how to go home
and deal with your family
after the election
at Thanksgiving.
So that's a huge range
of ideas and thoughts
and expertise represented just
really over the course of 24
or 48 hours on these three--
in two publications
and one radio station.
But I wanted to start with Naomi
and with that as a backdrop,
because Naomi is somebody
who has navigated
both waters, if we want to
think of them as separate ponds.
So she is somebody who has
written for the Washington
Post and the LA Times and
Nature and Science and The New
Statesman and on and on.
She's worked in the print,
she's worked in video,
she's written books, she's
written Op-Eds for newspapers,
for magazines, she's
done a TED Talk,
she's worked on a documentary.
So on the one hand, she's
very skilled at the popular.
Here are just two headlines--
one from a piece and
one from a book--
The Pope and the Planet--
we'd all read that--
Merchants of Doubt--
we all read that--
and then, maybe the
not so popular culture,
here's the title of one, The
Rejection of Continental Drift:
Theory and Method in
American Earth Science--
probably not something any
of these three would publish.
JAMES DAO: Maybe with
a different headline.
ANN MARIE LIPINSKI: Maybe
with a different headline.
And that's a key, actually,
what Jim just said.
And so I want to see if we can
learn from Naomi how she thinks
about those as very
separate disciplines,
but rising from the same well
of knowledge and expertise
that you bring to both.
So talk about coming at popular
pieces, popular culture pieces,
or publications in
the popular culture
with your academic background.
NAOMI ORESKES: Sure.
OK.
Thanks.
Well, thanks very much for
having me here and thanks,
Judy, for organizing
this and, Liz,
I have to say I do feel kind
of a weight of responsibility
being the token
academic on this panel.
So I guess the
best place to start
is just by saying I don't
think of them as being
separate ponds.
I've never thought of
the diverse work I do.
I work in science, I work
in history of science,
I work in what you
call the popular realm.
I never think of
them and I never
have thought of them as
different projects and that's
something that deans and
chairs have not always
understood, although
I think they do now,
and I'm in a very
nice place now where
now I get to be trotted
out as an exemplar of how
this can be done, but it
wasn't always that way.
So the first thing
you have to realize
is that I think you have to have
a conception of what you think
your project is and I guess
being an earth scientist,
for me, the metaphor
I've always had
is kind of the iceberg metaphor
that what I do in public
is a kind of the
tip of the iceberg.
It's the small piece that
stands out that people see,
people like yourself
or these folks,
but it's supported by this
giant mass of material
beneath the surface that
most of you don't see,
but that's the
part that supports
it, that's the part that
the upper part floats on.
And so all of you, as academics,
have that mass of work
that you've done that you've
worked incredibly hard on
or you've spent long
hours in the archives
or in the laboratory or in the
field or wherever you work.
And you have all this stuff at
your disposal that you can use.
And so I think that's
the starting point
is a sense of empowerment
based on your knowledge
and the knowledge
you have that if you
start to write about something
based on your research,
you know more about that
than probably anybody.
Right?
And so that's, I think, where
my public work comes from
is out of this
body, this big body,
of detailed work and long
hours spent in dusty archives
which Gabriella knows about.
Right?
So I thought,
maybe, I could just
say something of how I
wrote my first Op-Ed piece
because that's the other
second really important thing.
And I don't think the folks
on this panel will disagree,
but they may have a slightly
different view, because I
know sometimes editors work
with academics to figure out
what they might
want to write about,
but that's not how I came
to write my first Op-Ed.
I came to write my
first Op-Ed because I
had something I wanted to say.
And I think that's the
bottom line for anyone is,
do you have something to say?
If you don't, then as the
great sage Tom Lehrer said,
the least you can do is shut up.
So don't talk until you
have something to say,
but when you do,
that's the moment.
And so I think the key thing
is to sort of be aware,
to kind of go through the
world with an awareness of how
your work might
connect to something.
And when that moment
occurs, that's when you act.
And so some years ago,
more than 10 years ago, we
had some terrible wildfires
in Southern California
and my children were out
of school for a week.
We had a fire week.
Here we have snow days, but in
California, we have fire days.
And it was a quite traumatic
time in Southern California.
Lots of people were
displaced from their homes.
And my children and I--
and you couldn't
really go anywhere
because it was so
much smoke and dust.
It was not safe to be outside.
After three days of baking
cookies and things like that,
and I'm reading the papers--
and this is the
other thing, too,
is noticing what's
not being said.
So there were all these things
being written about the fires
and no one was
making the connection
to climate change, no one.
And I, personally, think that
of all the different things
that climate change does,
is already doing, and will
do to us, at least, if
you live in the west,
fires are the most important
thing because they're
really, really scary.
People are afraid
of fire, people
get it that fires destroy their
homes and their communities
and their lives and cost
billions of dollars in damage.
So fires connect climate
change to people's lives
in very real, tangible, and
emotionally present way.
And so I just wrote
something about it.
I wrote, basically,
something that said, guys,
you know climate change.
And I sent it over the transom
to the Los Angeles Times--
didn't know anybody.
And an editor there
saw it and liked it
and called me up and said,
we'd like to run with this.
And then over the next 24
hours, we worked together
to clean it up and
I learned a lot
working with an editor about
how to write a good Op-Ed piece.
You learn by working
with editors.
So after that experience,
then I realized, OK, this
is actually not that hard.
I mean it's different,
like I was just saying,
I mean the style of an
Op-Ed is different than what
we're used to in academic life.
You have to hit it hard, don't
bury the lead, main idea up
front, only one idea, not
17, no table of contents,
no footnotes, almost
no references--
and if they already have
to kind of explore-- well,
I guess now with
hyperlinks, you kind of do.
JAMES DAO: That's right.
NAOMI ORESKES: My first
Op-Ed was in the days before
a hyperlink--
I mean old fashioned
print-- all that kind thing.
So anyway, the point is
I had something to say
and I said it and
somebody was interested
and then things went from there.
So there's not really
like a magic trick
about writing an
Op-Ed, but you do
have to let go of a lot
of your academic concern
with detail, nuance, subtlety.
The art of an Op-Ed
piece, subtlety
is not kind of like
job one, although there
is a place for it at times.
It's not to say that the best
Op-Ed pieces is a sledgehammer,
it's not.
But it's just we've been so
trained to focus as academics
on the subtlety, the
nuance, the details,
and so you do have
to let go of some
of your academic sensibilities.
If you can find
someone to work with,
that's a really good thing,
but my initial Op-Eds were just
on my own, but I
was very lucky--
and this is something I think
we could do here at Harvard
and I'd actually like talk
to you more about this later.
So after I wrote my
first Op-Ed piece,
then I got an email
from someone at UCSD.
I was teaching in San
Diego at the time--
and just a small aside--
when I was in San Diego,
the New York Times never
accepted any of my Op-Ed
pieces, and then I moved here,
and suddenly like [INAUDIBLE].
So OK, better late than never.
I know it wasn't me.
But I got an email from someone
in our press and communication
office and she said, that was
a great piece, I loved it,
would you like to work
with me in the future?
And so, we did and we
had a great partnership
and it went like this.
I had something to say,
something happened,
I would write a draft,
I sent it to her--
Inga Kiddera was her name.
Inga would look at it, she'd
give me some suggestions--
she had been in journalism--
I would make them, and then she
would shop them around for me.
And that was a giant blessing
because, frankly, it's
hard to shop your
own Op-Ed pieces.
And nobody likes rejection,
but it's particularly--
if you're an academic and
you're used to getting reviews,
you get feedback, you
revise, you resubmit--
to have an Op-Ed
editor to say, sorry,
we're not interested and
no explanation, nothing--
because that's how it goes
because they're not obligation
to give--
they're not reviewers, right?
That was kind of hard, but
she would shop them for me.
And so working with Inga, we'd
place pieces, as Tara said,
Washington Post, Chicago
Tribune, Los Angeles Times,
San Francisco
Chronicle-- practically
every major newspaper
in this country
with the notable exception of
one in New York, but that's OK.
And here's the other
really important thing
I just want to say before
I pass on to the others.
So one thing I've really noticed
moving here from California--
it's not a criticism
of Harvard which is
an incredibly great university.
I'm totally proud and
thrilled to be here,
but we tend to sort of think
when we think about newspapers,
the media, we think about The
New York Times, The Boston
Globe, and that's fine.
They're absolutely
fantastic, amazing newspapers
and they reach lots
and lots of people.
But there are
millions and millions
of people in this country
who do not read The New York
Times and that could be hard
to believe being at Harvard--
or The Boston Globe or
even The Los Angeles Times.
There's this world of people are
out there that we don't reach
and this election has made
that incredibly clear,
if we didn't know it beforehand.
ANN MARIE LIPINSKI: So
thank you for that, Naomi,
and I wanted to turn to Katie.
So Naomi said something
very, very important.
She said she's home,
she's baking cookies,
there are fires all around
her, she had this idea
that fires connect
people to climate
change in a very real way.
And so embedded in
that observation
is that this was
incredibly timely.
The wolf was at the
door, she had knowledge,
and she jumped on
it very quickly.
There was a reason
for an editor to look
at that piece in that moment.
And I'm wondering
if you can talk
about the importance of
that, Katie, and conversely,
getting an idea, a
pitch, that's kind of--
it could happen
any day of the year
and there's not that sense
of urgency or timeliness
and how you think about
those two in different ways.
KATHLEEN KINGSBURY: Sure.
I can't overemphasize the
importance of timeliness.
If something is
happening, that's
when you should be contacting
an editor, not three days later.
I often, when I was
the Ideas editor,
would get a pitch about a topic
that was very, very important,
but not in the news
anymore and there was not
a lot of reason to start
talking about it again.
So within minutes of
something happening
is when you should be
reaching out to an editor,
when you should be
thinking about it.
So that talks a
lot to what Naomi
said which is always be
thinking about these things,
always be thinking
about what you have
to say on different topics
and areas of expertise
that you have so that
you can jump on it.
And I would, actually,
say the other good thing
to do is just talk
to editors in advance
and get to know editors,
have coffee with them.
I know I often would
make appointments
with academics or
other local voices
that we wanted to, someday,
have as contributors
thinking about--
often, ideas would come
through just a conversation
and someone would say,
I'm working on this topic
and I have a lot of research
on x and we would figure out
an angle together.
And that was one of the
things that I actually really
enjoyed about working with
Op-Eds is the idea that I could
help the person think
through what they
were trying to say on a topic.
It doesn't need to be a
700 word Op-Ed fully formed
when you turn it in.
It can be a nugget of an idea
that we can work together
to form into a piece.
The counter side
to that, the idea
that you have something
that could work any day,
it's often what works
is something that's
counter-intuitive so
something that breaks
the stereotypes around a
topic or that is interesting,
unique research that only you
are working on in that moment
or that only you are talking
about that will change
a reader's mind, for instance.
I always say, why are
we doing this piece now
is one of the questions
that I frequently
ask people who are
pitching Op-Eds to me
and kind of making sure that
when you're first approaching
the editor, that
you can say this is
why we're doing this piece now.
It's because this is a brand
new piece of research or this
is something that's on the
news or this is something
that only I can
bring this expertise
and the topic is extremely
relevant to your readers
because--
ANN MARIE LIPINSKI:
Can you, Katie,
so because you're The Boston
Globe and you sit in this--
you're awash in
academic institutions
and real and potential
contributors,
do you have any observations
about or maybe an example
of a really successful and also
maybe a less than successful
pitch that you've
had about something
related to academic
research and feels right
or does not in the moment?
KATHLEEN KINGSBURY: Sure.
I think that they're--
all you have to do is read the
Sunday "Idea" section and you'd
find successful
pitches from academics.
We often have pieces,
but things that are--
I'm trying to think,
of course, I'm
struggling now that you've asked
me and put me on the spot--
but we--
ANN MARIE LIPINSKI:
I should say,
very excitedly and happily,
Katie's mind is in a new place.
Although she edited ideas and
Sunday Op-Eds for some time,
she's the recently promoted
managing editor of The Boston
Globe so yea for Katie.
KATHLEEN KINGSBURY: Thank you.
I would say that there
are great examples.
We did a piece about
the history of the word
racism a couple of weeks ago.
I didn't actually
edit that, but I
was part of the initial process
of soliciting it and bringing
it to The Globe.
And it was one of
those pieces where
it could have been very
academic and jargony
and I know that there
was a lot of work
put into making it something
that a lay reader could read
and get through--
early drafts were
sort of dense--
but the writer worked very
closely with the editor
and made it something
that felt very accessible
to the average reader.
I think that there are a couple
of pitfalls that writers often
find themselves in which
make things not successful.
So for instance, what
I was saying earlier
was there's this
phenomenon called editing
by committee in
which you will go
through the first
edit with a writer
and they will send you back
a note that says something
to the effect of,
OK well, I just
need to share this
around my department.
That almost never
works for an editor
because what comes
back from that process
is a lot of caveats being
added to the piece when--
Going back to
something Naomi said,
really what works
the best is when
you have a straight point
that you're trying to make
and you're using
supporting evidence around
that as opposed to something
that becomes muddied
because you want to make sure
that this person gets credit
for their research or a side
is added because you want
to make sure it feels nuanced.
Nuance is important
and, in fact, I
think people go too far in
terms of taking nuance out,
because I think often you do
want to have those caveats,
but you don't want to
have the caveats take away
from your argument and
that's often what can happen.
It's when you
start saying things
like I'm making this
really strident point,
but there is all this research
that says the opposite.
And I feel like there is
a pressure in academia
to make sure everyone
in your department
feels like they are in the
know about what you're writing
or about this excellent
opportunity you
have to contribute to The
Boston Globe or et cetera.
But when that process starts
to take away from the punch
or impact that the
piece can have,
that's when it gets in the way.
And so the other
thing that I always
appreciate, as I mentioned,
is when someone wants
to credit their bosses' work.
That happens all the time.
It's constantly like--
and I want to say--
in the drafts, obviously.
This doesn't often ever
really make it into the paper,
because that's one of the
first things, as an editor,
that you take out, frankly.
So you'll get a piece that's
like this Op-Ed wouldn't have
been possible without
the previous research
by my department chair.
So just know going in that
if you want to do that,
you're going to be really--
it's going to be hard
to find an editor who's
going to let that
end up in the paper.
ANN MARIE LIPINSKI: I'm
smiling because it's also
completely antithetical to
what would happen in a newsroom
where reporters will never
give their bosses credit
for anything.
[LAUGHTER]
It's the precise
opposite, culturally.
KATHLEEN KINGSBURY: Right.
ANN MARIE LIPINSKI: The
editors only ruin things.
Your bosses ruin your best work.
KATHLEEN KINGSBURY: Exactly.
ANN MARIE LIPINSKI: One of the
great mysteries of the universe
is how the pieces get chosen for
The New York Times Op-Ed page.
You're in the really
fortunate position
to be overwhelmed
with submissions.
You're in the really
difficult position
of being overwhelmed
with submissions.
So, Jim, can you just
talk about that process?
So you're thinking about
tomorrow's page, what's
been the run up to what
we will read there,
what will appear there--
in print or online.
JAMES DAO: Sure.
I just want to say I've only
been there 10 months so I have
yet to reject one of Naomi's.
NAOMI ORESKES: But
it will happen.
JAMES DAO: And it's true that
we don't give explanations
because, as I explained to one
writer, if that's what we did,
that's all we would do.
So I'd love to be
able to boil it down,
but it's, of course, it's
like a newsroom, in fact.
It's sausage making
and it's sausage
making as ugly as anything that
happens in the news operation.
But I'll sort of run you
through a typical day
where we start with
the morning meeting.
We all come in trying to have
read not just our paper, which
is enough of an ordeal, but
has skimmed other papers
and have a sense
of what's going on.
And we discuss what is the
big story that we care about?
What is the running story we're
going to continue to follow?
And what is the role of
opinion in this process?
And that, in and of itself, is
a really complicated question
because opinion is so much
more diverse and broad
than it once was.
The Op-Ed page of The Times
historically was two pieces
and columnists and
it still is that--
two pieces by outside
writers, often academics,
but they could be
novelists, it could
be regular people, and then
two of our regular columnists.
But today, we are now
online only essays.
We are the Sunday Review
which is 12 to 15 very
often long style essays,
sometimes reported
and sometimes personal
narrative, sometimes
standard opinionated Op-Eds with
a prescription and a problem.
We are the international
New York Times,
which has its own group of
outside international writers
writing from across the globe.
And there's a whole variety
of online types of pieces
that we do.
One of our favorites
is something
called The Stone which is a
philosopher's blog, basically.
It's part of the
Op-Ed operation.
Some of The Stone essays get
into the paper or the Sunday
Review, but most of
them just live online
and it has a
dedicated readership.
Maybe, if there's any
philosophers here,
you've actually looked at it.
And we have others like
that that are developing.
So as Katie pointed
out, timeliness is huge.
We're looking for pieces
that can go-- sometimes,
we get Op-Eds within an hour
of an event taking place.
And very often--
KATHLEEN KINGSBURY: And that's
when you should be pitching.
JAMES DAO: But very often,
they're astonishingly good
and we try not to
distinguish between what
goes online versus
what goes in the paper
because, more and more, we
are purely online operation,
but we do give a little bit more
care and tending to the paper
because the readers are a
little bit more careful there
and we have more
time to work on them.
But we get full-fledged
850 word Op-Eds
within an hour or two of major
events and if they are good,
we will put them online
as quickly as we can,
sometimes within an
hour or two hours
depending on the
quality of them.
What I would say to sort of be
the counter voice on timeliness
is every clever reporter
has figured out,
over the course of their
career, that you can make
almost anything
feel timely if you
have the right framing for it.
And the key to anything,
whether it's a news story
or whether it's an Op-Ed, is
that as Naomi points out very
correctly, you should
write about what you know
and what you care about.
We receive 1,000 pictures
a day about people
who want to tell
us why Trump won
and really, we don't care
almost from any of you.
We have columnists, editorial
writers, and big brains
across the globe trying
to tell us what that is.
We're probably not
going to really care
about your opinion on that.
What we are going
to care about is
if you have some amazing
data about voting
patterns in a particular
part of the country
that illuminate how a
certain demographic voted--
that could be
really interesting.
We had a pollster from Cornell
who did that and his material
made it, it was only online
because we had such a flood
of post-election stuff.
But it just cut an interesting
slice out of the electorate
that was really
interesting to us
and we thought illuminated
a part of what was going on.
Presumably, any
researcher doing,
no matter how niche or esoteric,
has some sort of resonance
for people and that's the
crucial part of figuring out
whether you can make a New York
Times Op-Ed because we're not--
as popular as we are in college
towns, most of our readers
are not academics,
most of our readers
are not going to know
your subjects very well.
They're smart generalists,
they're sophisticated readers.
What they want to do is to take
your nugget of information,
your research whether it's
history or science or politics,
and your ability to
pull back and say
this is why this matters to
lots of people is what's going
can make the difference
between a piece
that we take or don't take.
ANN MARIE LIPINSKI: How
many unassigned pieces
do you get over the
transom every day, roughly,
an estimate?
JAMES DAO: It's hundreds.
And I personally will wake up to
30 in my inbox and many of them
I will just farm out to
others to read, some of them
I'll try to read.
ANN MARIE LIPINSKI:
And what's the best--
JAMES DAO: It's both a
blessing and a curse.
It's not a curse--
the curse part of it isn't
just that it's a lot to read
and we can't keep up with
it, but to some degree,
we want to be able to direct
where the Op-Ed page is
going on our own.
And we could just run
things that were sent to us
every day of the week
for our entire careers.
What we try to do
as much as possible
is to step back and
say here's a thought
that we think people
aren't dealing with
and then think of who the
right writer is for that,
whether it's a novelist or
a journalist or an academic,
and that's where your
relationships with editors
do matter.
It not only helps you
when you do pitch a story,
but sometimes we'll
come to you because we
know that you've done research
on something interesting
or we know that
you've just come out
with a book on a particular
topic that was totally
meaningless and obscure
to us until that moment
when, suddenly, it wasn't
and it really mattered.
So our ability to have you on
our Rolodexes is important.
But we publish--
I don't know, we counted
it up the other day--
the operation I oversee
probably publishes
over 100 things a week between
small online and long form
in the Sunday Review.
And then there's video
and now there's audio
and there's just an incredible
array of things we now do.
Weeding through that stuff
is a huge part of the day.
And I guess, the last point to
go beyond the timeliness part
of it is because Op-Ed has
evolved a lot in the years
and it's not just policy,
problem, prescription type
writing which is what it once
was and which we still value
and we still do, particularly
at this moment when we have
a new administration where
God knows where they're going,
but you know, perhaps,
it's a persuadable moment
and it's a time for
people to weigh in.
But we also we also run first
person essays that are not even
about a problem, necessarily.
They're experiential, they're
beautifully written very often,
but they tell us something
about a place in the world
or about a state of mind or
could be about a problem,
as well.
And you know that
type of essay often
is written by an
academic, as well.
It's going to sound idiotic
for me to say this, but study
us, study not just
the daily Op-Ed page,
but study the Sunday Review
and think about what you like
and what works
for you and that's
a very important part of the
learning process in terms
of figuring out what we
do and how your work might
fit into what we do.
ANN MARIE LIPINSKI: Iris, so
you work in a different medium.
On the one hand, you
do publish things
that would look like
they could work in print
or they could work on
cognoscente or [INAUDIBLE]
online and its portfolio.
But I wanted you to talk about
the difference between what
you're looking
for and who you're
looking for when you're
looking for Op-Ed pieces
we're going to hear.
There's been an explosion
in the last couple of years
in listening to opinion and
this very energetic podcast
environment that we're
enjoying right now.
Talk a little bit about how
you're choosing or assigning
that's different from what
your newspaper colleagues might
be doing.
IRIS ADLER: Well,
first of all, I
would say that the
criteria we use to choose
a good cognoscente piece--
they're very similar
to the criteria
we use for an on-air piece.
And some of those attributes
have been talked about--
the ability to be concise.
While our cognoscente pieces
might be up to 800 words,
often we'll take
those exact pieces
and turn them into
radio commentaries
and then we face
said academia writer,
we say, OK, now it's going to be
cut to 200 words or 300 words.
It's really a shocking process
and we get a lot of resistance.
But as you all know,
it is very difficult
to be listening to the radio
or whatever platform you listen
and have someone
just talk at you
without the inclusion
of soundbytes
or other kinds of sounds.
So the length,
literally, is two minutes
and that's what you get and
it's very difficult taking
that writer from 800
words to two minutes,
but it's absolutely critical and
some people don't want to do it
and that's fine.
But in either case,
we really need
to be very focused whether it's
a cognoscente piece or radio
piece--
I think someone has
talked-- but we're not
dealing with big topics here.
There was a very
prominent Harvard academic
who used to write
for us and his topics
would be like how
do we fix education.
I mean we really, really do need
a very small, but compelling
byte.
We also have emphasized
more particularly
for the radio or
podcast, as you said,
this little narrative style.
Ever since the huge success of
This American Life and serial
that storytelling
narrative has sort of
infiltrated every part of the
audio world, whatever platform
we're talking about.
And so often in our cognoscente
pieces or our radio pieces,
if the point could be wrapped
in some kind of narrative,
it makes it more
compelling for the listener
and people are just
used to this now.
So we often help people try
and find something of a story
to help illustrate their point.
One of the big differentiators--
and this sounds so obvious,
but it's something we have
to explain to people all
the time-- that just because
you're a brilliant writer
does not mean that you're
a great voice on the radio.
And sometimes, you're
a brilliant talker
and then you get
someone in a studio,
you put a mic in front of them,
and it's kind of daunting.
You've all done this.
You're sitting there alone in
a studio, the mic, an engineer
and producers sort
of talking at you.
They're saying
now sound natural.
Not everybody could do it.
We have some people who do
it brilliantly all the time--
Nancy Gertner comes to mind
who we use a lot-- from the Law
School.
So it's the actual
voice, but then there's
what I call the
sort of voiciness.
You could see why Naomi's a
great writer because she has--
like right away, we would call
it like pops through the air.
She just has that
kind of energy.
And again, you can be brilliant
and articulate and just not
be able to bring that
kind of energy that--
ANN MARIE LIPINSKI:
Can someone learn that?
Can you help them achieve that?
IRIS ADLER: Here's what
I think you could do.
You could have someone--
like literally, I tell people
stand in front of the mirror
and practice every night and
record yourself and then listen
back.
Because when you
listen back, you really
get a sense of how flat
you could sound, how dull
you could sound.
And I will often coach people
as they're in the studio
and say it's going to sound
very exaggerated to you,
but you need to bring energy
and emphasis which goes back
to the more important point
that if someone is really
passionate about a
topic, if they can bring
that passion both to their
writing and to the air,
it is really useful because
radio is a very intimate forum
and it's very hard, I think,
to be inauthentic on the radio
or at least to be good.
You know people always
point to Ira Glass who's
the-- you all know, the huge
radio This American Life star.
And he sounds when you
hear him on the air
so authentic just like he's
sitting down and just talking.
But every word that Ira
writes is written out
and his ums are written.
This is the sort
of famous thing--
you know those ums he
does and those like, wait,
let me correct
myself here thing--
this is all written down.
So people who are
really talented at it--
and they're few
and far between--
know how to write
to sound authentic,
but for the rest of us, we
just need to be able to do it.
And I think often, some
people, it's just practice
and just getting
comfortable so they
can sort of be self-revealing.
For other people, they're
just not going to get there.
ANN MARIE LIPINSKI: You totally
ruined This American Life
for many people today.
NAOMI ORESKES: Now, you're
going to tell us Garrison
Keillor isn't authentic.
[LAUGHTER]
IRIS ADLER: I don't know him.
ANN MARIE LIPINSKI:
I wanted to ask just
so we know how the [INAUDIBLE].
I wanted to ask you guys one
more sort of lightning round
question and we're going to
open it up to your questions
and I want to assure you
all that I'm going to end
no later than a quarter to two.
I know some of you have classes
to teach a, but b, some of you
probably want to have some
quick introductory conversations
with our guests here today, too.
So they'll be there'll
be time for that.
But the one sort of lightning
round question I wanted to ask
is and, Jim, you hinted at it.
So we've been talking about kind
of a traditional Op-Ed writing
both for newspapers
and for radio,
but I wanted to talk about
innovations in this space.
So The Times is
doing Op-Docs and we
think now about aspects of
journalism being performative,
in a sense, and not to take away
from fairness or verisimilitude
or any of those
important traditions,
but that just ink on paper
or pixels or airwaves--
that it's not always sufficient.
We're thinking about the
visual nature of these pieces.
We are thinking about sound.
So if we could just
sort of quickly--
and, Jim, I know The
Times has experimented
in this space a lot--
started some things,
stopped some things.
But just if you could
each just really quickly
talk about something that
you're excited about that's
on the horizon
and how, maybe, we
should be thinking differently
or more innovatively
about telling these stories.
I'll start with you.
JAMES DAO: Want me to start?
ANN MARIE LIPINSKI: Yeah.
JAMES DAO: Well, can
I name three things?
So well, you mentioned or I
actually talked a little bit
about The Stone.
So one of the things we're
doing this coming year
are mostly online.
They're not blogs, but
they're formats, platforms
for essentially essays.
And I guess I can
talk about this.
It's a little bit
proprietary, but we're
hoping to start one
on religion and just
talking about
religion in daily life
from all religious points of
view, anywhere on the globe.
And we're expecting some of the
writers will be theologists,
some of them will be
practicing ministers or rabbis,
but we're hoping much of it
will be just people talking
about religion and how it
guides their daily life
through their
religious experiences
from that sort of ground up.
And that will, we're
hoping, have written essays,
sometimes it will be
pieces off the news, who
knows, if there's significant
news in the religion world.
Some of it we're hoping
will be audio, some of it
could be video, as well.
And that will be
just its own thing
we're hoping to create
in the coming year.
Similarly, we're planning
a mainly online feature
on Vietnam and how Vietnam
the war that has shaped
American life today in all
its many ways, whether it's
having to do with foreign
policy or military policy,
military strategy, how
Vietnam was experienced
and still how the war
is still experienced
by people in Vietnam today.
And that's going to
be a running feature
over the course of the year.
ANN MARIE LIPINSKI: Will
you bring in other media?
Not just--
JAMES DAO: Yep.
ANN MARIE LIPINSKI: OK.
JAMES DAO: We're doing
this sort of in conjunct
with Ken Burns who's got a big
series coming out on Vietnam.
We are playing with, as I
was talking to Iris and Katie
about, with audio and trying to
go the route of doing podcasts.
And those are still
being worked on.
We haven't quite figured
out how to do them,
but certainly some
of it will probably
involve some of our columnists,
people like maybe Gail Collins
or Nick Krostof's kind of a
natural for any experiment
that you want to try whether
it's social media or video.
And now we're going to launch
him on audio maybe and see
how that works.
360 video is the other
thing he's going to try.
It's an amazing thing.
The camera's-- I don't know
if anybody's seen them,
but 360 video cameras are the
size of a tennis ball and you
can put them down and just
let them run for a couple
of minutes and it's just
going to be a whole other part
of what we do, both in the
newsroom and in the opinion
section.
ANN MARIE LIPINSKI: OK.
Katie, I have an example
in my head for The Globe,
but maybe you want to
talk about a different one
and that was the approach you
took to writing about guns--
KATHLEEN KINGSBURY: Oh, sure.
ANN MARIE LIPINSKI: --which
included a massive tweet
storm--
KATHLEEN KINGSBURY: Yeah.
ANN MARIE LIPINSKI: --along
with the print presentation,
but maybe you could just talk
a little bit about that which
I thought was very innovative in
that space and with that issue.
KATHLEEN KINGSBURY:
And that's something
that we've actually been
experimenting, generally, with.
I would echo, we're also
doing a lot of experimenting
with 360 video.
We're currently working
with some MIT academics
on a project mapping
the Charles River.
We have access to
the USS Constitution
that's in dry-docks right
now that we're doing
this cool history project on.
And what Ann Marie
is referring to
is a editorial that
we wrote back in June.
It was a project
that I led looking
in the aftermath of
the Orlando shooting,
calling for a ban
on assault rifles.
And what we did for
that project is we
approached it in three ways--
one for print, one for
our online desktop,
mobile experience,
and then for social.
The print product was probably
something that all of you
would be very familiar with.
We wrapped the front
page of The Globe
on a Thursday morning
with the editorial
as well as some graphics kind
of making the case that we
should ban assault rifles.
Then, we wrote a very
traditional editorial.
And then for digital,
it was much more
of an interactive experience.
We also had several
calls to action within it
so we targeted six
senators that we
knew were vulnerable
on this topic
and asked them to change
their vote and most of them
lost at the beginning
of November.
They received thousands of
tweets via The Boston Globe
website and that was something
that was really heartening.
Kelly Ayotte was
one, in particular,
that probably because
of the local ties that
came under assault, basically,
off from The Globe's website
and ultimately changed her vote
which was something that we
were really proud to see.
And then finally, we did this
really innovative project which
is something we're
experimenting with more and more
of on social.
Every five seconds or excuse
me, every five minutes,
we posted the name and age
of a gun mass shooting victim
since Sandy Hook and
the killings there.
And that was--
ANN MARIE LIPINSKI: Every
single American victim
since Sandy Hook.
KATHLEEN KINGSBURY: Exactly.
Well, every single victim of a
shooting in the United States.
Some of them were--
a couple of them were
actually foreigners.
But the power of
that was something
we were experimenting with
and we weren't expecting,
but the power of that
to see those names
and to see how frequently they
came and this was something
that took 38 hours
for us to accomplish
was to list every victim's name.
We had a very stringent
standard for who
would be included in that list,
and yet, it took that long.
We took over The Globe's
Twitter handle and particularly
the part when we are talking
about the children who
have died that it became very
poignant very quickly to see
those names come
one after the other
and ending on the Orlando
Pulse Nightclub shooting.
Just to kind of see
the raw power of that
was something that we've
tried to take and apply
in other ways.
So we're actually now,
almost in every major project
that we do through the
newsroom and the Op-Ed page,
looking at it through that
lens of what should we
be doing in print, what
should we be doing in digital,
and what should we
be doing on social.
And we just had a huge
piece about trolley accident
that happened 100 years ago that
we did the similar approach to
and had a lot of success with.
ANN MARIE LIPINSKI:
So, Naomi, I'm
wondering if you think
about your pieces now.
You talked about how when
you wrote that first piece
for the LA Times these
options didn't really exist.
Do you think about
that more acutely now?
It's not just I write this
thing, I give it to them,
it goes into the newspaper.
Are you thinking about
building audience
or trying new forms
of storytelling?
NAOMI ORESKES: OK.
To me, those are two
different questions.
In terms of the
format, not so much.
I mean different
things come your way.
I love radio.
I have to say radio is my
favorite thing because you just
talk.
It's like you get in
that booth and it's
like you're in the zone and
everything else drops away.
You don't have to worry about
the bags under your eyes
or what you're wearing.
So I just love radio and I
always say yes the opportunity
to be on the radio.
So don't be afraid of radio.
Radio is an academic's dream
come true because it's you
and your words and
your voice so I just
think radio is fantastic.
I wouldn't say that
it's changed how
I think about what I'm doing.
I'm not sitting
around thinking, oh,
could I do a podcast on this?
I'm not doing that,
although maybe I will--
I don't know.
But in terms of the
storytelling part,
absolutely definitely
and actually,
my great postdoc,
Jeff Zupan, is here
who's working with me right
now on a kind of novel approach
to climate change solutions.
So yes, I've certainly been
thinking about that for a while
and I would say my
work with journalists
and the work I've done trying
to reach a broader audience
has certainly made
me think much more
about how we tell
our stories and why,
as academics, what some of
the obstacles are for us.
That as academics, we
have certain conventions
of academic life that
we subscribe to that
absolutely do get in the way--
no question about that.
And so I think where
I'm at right now
and I hope Judy's
listening very closely,
I'm not so much
interested in changing
what I do for journalists.
I'm pretty happy
with what I've done
in the journalistic
popular domain.
It's more like I think I'd
like to become involved now
in a movement to change how
academics write for each other
because I've come to think I
don't actually understand why
we, as academics, insist
on writing books that
are excruciatingly boring
and that no one will read.
I mean it makes no sense
to me and I'm fully
tenured so I can say this now--
and I'm not looking
for another job
and I don't want to be a dean.
But really, I mean
it's really this kind
of extremely interesting mystery
about how and why we write
these incredibly
boring books that only
17 other people in
our field would read
and it wasn't always that way.
And as a historian of
science, I can tell you
that we had Harvard
professors of geology right
here in this institution
who, in the 1920s,
were writing bestsellers
about continental drift, what
would have been considered
a very academic topic.
So some of the issues about
why we, as academics, do
the things we do,
so I'd like to see
the academic side of this
world begin to move and shift
and think more about who our
audience is and why have we
defined our audience in such
an excruciating now way.
ANN MARIE LIPINSKI:
That's great.
And, Iris, the last word to you.
If somebody comes
to you, are you
putting a premium on how
innovative the approach might
be?
Are you looking for new
ways of storytelling?
IRIS ADLER: We're
pretty committed
to podcast development
I mean I would
say that's, as a senior manager,
90% of my job right now.
We kind of understand that
nobody under the age of 40,
let's say, owns a
radio and that even--
no, they don't, they listen
on iPhones or their iPads
and even cars which are
now internet connected.
We're going to lose that
listening platform, as well,
listening to radios in cars.
So we're very committed to
developing innovative content
in the digital space.
And for us right now, that means
audio because it's on demand
and it's portable and that's
what these generations coming
up expect and want just like we
do with television, et cetera.
So we're very
committed to podcasting
and I'm happy to say we
produced a very successful one
with The Times this year.
We took their
"Modern Love" column
and we produced it as a podcast.
You should go to iTunes and
subscribe if you haven't yet.
We're on the verge, just
hiring people right now,
working with The
Boston Globe to produce
a podcast on the Isabella
Stewart Gardner theft
as a kind of eight part
serial like series.
And so we're always looking
for great content and voices
for podcasts.
ANN MARIE LIPINSKI: Great.
Thank you.
So I wanted to turn to
you all for your questions
for our guests today and
my guess is you have many.
And if I could
just ask, if people
would introduce
themselves before they
ask their questions.
AUDIENCE: My name
is Peter Girguis.
I'm in the Department of
Organismic and Evolutionary
Biology.
Thank you all very much.
This was fantastic.
I have two questions.
I'll start with one that's
more straightforward
and one that might
be more challenging.
The first is I think
Iris addressed this.
To what extent are you open
to academics and others
bringing you something
that they have developed
if it moves beyond a podcast,
some sort of innovative way
of communicating what
we do to the public?
And how might you expect
your various institutions
to engage these maybe sort
of more innovative, if not
unconventional, ways
of communicating?
So first one.
ANN MARIE LIPINSKI: Do
you have an example?
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
So let's say that there is--
this is a kind of shooting
from the hip here example,
but let's say that I'm
a deep sea biologist
and I'm interested in engaging
the broader public in helping
me identify and characterize
some of these deep sea
organisms that
people haven't seen
before, just sort of the
citizen science movement, right?
And so let's say I have a web
platform or an app or something
that allows folks
to do this and let's
say there's broad engagement.
To what extent or how might I
approach you all to say, hey,
can you help me
get this word out?
Is that something that your
office does or another office?
So that's an example.
The second question is the
bigger more difficult one.
IRIS ADLER: Can I just stop
you there for a second?
AUDIENCE: Yes.
IRIS ADLER: Never use
the words will you
help me get the word out
because that immediately
signals to us that this is a
sort of PR kind of request.
AUDIENCE: Right.
Understood.
So perhaps then to
rephrase it, to what
extent are you interested
in being a part of this?
So the second question is,
how are you all viewing
this change in the
way information
and rather misinformation is
being presented as information
and how do we engage with
you all on topics like that.
So if there is a
position or an idea
we have that touches
upon that sort
of the fake news
and the like, where
are those boundaries drawn?
Frankly, how do you
all as journalists
decide what is and
isn't ethically
appropriate to take a position
on or does that rest with us?
If you see where
I'm going with that.
ANN MARIE LIPINSKI: So maybe if
we could get one or two of you
to answer the first question
and then one or two of you to--
I mean, we could spend the day
on fake news which many of us
are obsessing about
and it's not just
coming from those who would
intentionally do harm,
it's coming from our
own industry, frankly.
KATHLEEN KINGSBURY: I'm happy
to tackle the first one.
ANN MARIE LIPINSKI: OK.
Go, Katie.
KATHLEEN KINGSBURY: I think
that we have actually,
at the Idea section,
we have actually
experimented a lot with trying
to work with academics where
they are.
So one of the things that I
was going to bring up before I
started talking about the
assault rifle campaign was that
one of the things that we've
been doing lately is taking
artifacts or different
manuscripts and transcripts
and things like that and having
academics essentially annotate
them for us and have it be kind
of an actual back and forth
about a document or something--
a piece of science or--
One of the things that is going
to be in the paper on Sunday
is some MIT professors
have come up
with these mathematical quizzes.
And they're making
a broader point,
but we're working on how to
make them online and make
them interactive.
If you have
something like an app
that you wanted to
work with us on,
we would probably
figure out a way
to repurpose it and
put it in our paper
or put it online
and then include
an introduction or something
that directs traffic.
I mean, I think that
there are always
ways to work these things
out and I, personally,
have always been open to trying
to find a solution on those.
And so I would never hesitate
to kind of approach an editor
with a project like
that as long as you're
going into it with an open mind
that the solution might not
be one that works for you, too.
IRIS ADLER: Yeah.
I think it depends
a little bit how
mission central your
project might be to us.
If it's this fascinating new
way of understanding this world
that you describe and there's a
way that it can be incorporated
into our platforms and
be of joint benefit
editorially to
you as well as us,
we're always open
to those ideas.
ANN MARIE LIPINSKI: And
on the fake news issue?
JAMES DAO: You're looking at me.
So actually, I'm not entirely
sure I understand the question,
but fake news is just a
big news story right now
and how it exists and how it
was disseminated the way it was
and why people
believed it are all
like fascinating
elements of a news story
that we're also weighing
in as an Op-Ed page.
There's questions about
how social media--
we've ran a couple of
pieces in the Sunday Review
a couple of weeks ago about
how it's easy to game Facebook
and Reddit, for instance,
to disseminate this stuff
and there's a huge appetite
for it and it's profitable.
And our News section came
out with a similar story
a few days later.
In terms of whether
we, as the Op-Ed page,
are susceptible to fakery is,
of course, always been a problem
and always been an issue.
And the way we deal with it
is we have fact checkers.
The front line editors and
there's about a dozen of them
that work with me, part of
their job is to fact check,
but we also have a
team of fact checkers
that go through everything.
And every piece gets at least
some basic fact checking.
But because we are opinion,
we're allowing for a certain--
is not the stretching of fact,
but we're allowing people
to use what they can
say is demonstrably
reasonably provable fact
to build an argument.
And if the basic foundation
of that is true and checkable,
then that passes our first line
test of whether we'll run it
or not.
NAOMI ORESKES: Can I
engage you, though,
in a question related
to this because a lot
of my work in the last 10
years has been about not--
I wouldn't call it fake news,
but disinformation promoted
by people for various reasons
and the promotion of what
I think people now
call false equivalence.
And there's no question that
the mainstream media are
part of this story because
of the so many times
that mainstream
media have quoted,
let's say, at least in
the realm of science,
nonscientific sources
like the Cato Institute
on a question of science about
which any scientist would
have agreed that what the
Cato Institution was saying
was not correct
scientifically, not
supported by scientific facts.
And yet in an article in The
New York Times, Washington Post,
The Boston Globe,
you know wherever,
you would see those quotations
juxtaposed with a scientist,
therefore creating the
impression that there
was a scientific debate which,
as I've shown in my work,
is the whole point of
that kind of thing.
So that's one
question I have is I
guess my perception from my
view is that the media, the news
media, have not been as
alert to that problem
as I think they need to
be-- that's one thing.
And even though many
journalists I've talked to say,
oh, we don't do that anymore.
We don't make that
mistake anymore.
We know we shouldn't do that,
yet I see it all the time.
And then the other part has
to do with the Opinion page
and this is a tricky
one because, obviously,
opinion pages are opinions.
But I have seen cases-- and I'm
going to be specific to The New
York Times now because
I'm using facts--
where someone on
the opinion page,
either a guest writer or
one of your own columnists--
and if you're interested, later,
I can tell you offline who--
has said something in an
opinion a matter of fact
that was demonstrably false
and used a false claim
to build the opinion piece.
And one time-- this
happened a few years ago
before I had friends on the
editorial page who I would now
reach out to and call--
but where this happened
with a particular
columnist where I had
seen it happen more than once.
And on the third time, it
happened to be about a topic
that I knew very well that
one of my own students
had written their honors
thesis on was a claim that
was demonstrably false--
I had the documentation.
And I did send something
to The New York Times,
never received any reply.
Yeah.
And that false claim is now,
if you go to The New York Times
microfiche, it's there.
So I guess I have two questions.
One is about how you think
about it, but the more important
question, I think, for this
audience is, what should we do?
So we're reading
The New York Times,
we see something that we know is
false as scholars and academics
who have worked on
it, yet it's now there
in The New York Times.
What is the right
way for us to try
to engage with you to try to
correct something like that
and prevent that
from happening again?
JAMES DAO: Sure.
So we pride ourselves
in how many corrections
we run and we run a lot.
And they can be
unbelievably arcane,
but it's a crucial
part of what we do.
And as both the newsroom
employee and a newsroom editor
and now the Op-Ed
editor, I generally
believe that we should err on
the side of correcting when
we can, because sometimes
it is a little bit
hard to get to get to
ground truth on some
of the issues that come up.
But the columnists, believe
it or not, make mistakes.
In fact, I woke up this
morning to two complaints
about columns over the weekend
and we will take that up
with them.
They have their
own fact checkers.
They try to run this stuff
through their own process,
but journalism is an
incredibly imperfect process
and that goes for
the Op-Ed page, too.
We are a self-correcting
institution
and we self-correct in two ways.
Sometimes, when there's
a clear factual error
that somebody can tell us
is a clear factual error,
we will push--
most editors attitude is we
will do a correction on it
and that will go
online under the piece
as well as in the paper.
Sometimes, the
problems of coverage
are more nuanced or complicated
and they're not simple facts.
And we correct by
trying to come up
with different viewpoints or
different types of stories
to broaden the
understanding of an issue
beyond what might have been a
less than accurate portrayal.
NAOMI ORESKES: But if I can
just press slightly, I'm sorry,
but what should we do?
Because when I did reach
out, I never got a response.
And how do we communicate
with you about these issues?
JAMES DAO: There is this--
I'll be honest, I don't
know where you find it,
but we have a corrections
editor for the entire news
organization.
NAOMI ORESKES: You
mean the public editor?
JAMES DAO: No, you can go to
the public editor, if you want,
and a public editor
may take it up
or they may send the note to me.
But there is an editor
who just handles
corrections for the entire--
NAOMI ORESKES: So
that's the right place
to go, not the Op-Ed page.
JAMES DAO: And I'm trying--
I don't know the email off
hand, but it's probably
where you find corrections
in the newspaper.
You will see an email there
and you send your correction
to there and, believe it or
not, they go through all of them
and then they either
dispel them immediately
if it doesn't look like
it's a correctable error
or they send it off
to people like me
and then I give it to
another editor who will then
try to get to ground truth.
So we are constantly
dealing-- and that's really--
if you know an editor, you
can always send them a note.
NAOMI ORESKES: And that's
what I would do now.
Just curious, though,
because lots of people
don't necessarily know editors.
JAMES DAO: But there is a public
process and it's laid out,
I think it's probably a whole
page on The Times website
that explains the
corrections process.
IRIS ADLER: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: I am Brigitte
Madrian and I'm a professor
at the Harvard Kennedy School.
I work on the behavioral
economics of household
financial decision making.
I have, I guess, a more
logistical question.
So in my discipline,
economics, if you're
trying to publish
a paper, it would
be considered an
ethical violation
to submit your paper to
more than one journal
at the same time.
On the other hand, if you're
trying to write a book,
you could shop your
book proposal around
to multiple publishers
and find the best deal.
So I guess I'm asking for those
of us who have never written
an Op-Ed before, what are
the ethical norms for getting
an Op-Ed published?
Can you only shop it
around one place at a time
so you have to do
it sequentially?
Or could you send it to
200 different outlets
and if 150 of them
say they love it,
you could publish it
in all 150 of them?
KATHLEEN KINGSBURY: I would
say definitely, one at a time.
Never offer an Op-Ed
to an editor that's not
an exclusive to that editor.
JAMES DAO: Yeah, I
would second that.
ANN MARIE LIPINSKI:
So can I just
then ask about the
tension between
that sequential offering and
earlier comments about you're
getting things within
an hour of an event
and you want things
that are very--
three days from now is too late.
So that system presumes
that an editor's
getting back to you
instantly to say I love or I
don't love this piece.
So how do you navigate
between those?
KATHLEEN KINGSBURY: I often
suggest putting an expire time
or date on your email
saying if I don't hear back
from you by this time, then I
will assume that you are not
interested and I will move on.
I frequently find myself,
I can't speak for Jim,
but I have 56,000 emails
that are unread right now.
[LAUGHTER]
NAOMI ORESKES: That
makes me feel better.
KATHLEEN KINGSBURY: I
literally get thousands
of e-mails every day and it's
a combination of the fact
that I have always had a foot
in the newsroom and a foot
in opinion and with ideas, we
did reported pieces and opinion
pieces so I think I get
more than most people.
But the point
being, I often find
myself sending a note to
someone whose pitch I am reading
a day later or two days later
then I should be and saying,
have you placed
this somewhere else?
I don't have the
expectation that you've
been waiting for me
to get back to you
because of that timeliness and
that importance and timeliness.
So as long as you're
clear up front
saying, if I don't hear
from you by this time,
I think that's fair game to
move on to the next place.
JAMES DAO: It's good advice.
NAOMI ORESKES: I can
make one suggestion
that could be helpful, too.
Sometimes, you might have
an idea for something,
like something's
coming up and you
anticipate that you might
have something to say.
So one of the pieces
I'm most proud of
was one I did in
The Washington Post
when the fourth assessment
report of the IPCC came out.
And I knew that wants
to report came out,
they would be swamped
with suggestions,
but I had an idea
for something I
wanted to say in
advance of the release.
And so I sent it to them
two weeks ahead of time.
I said, here's a piece
that's anticipating
the release of the AR4.
I think this would be great
to run a couple of days
before it comes out.
And they did and that
piece got huge attention
because it was actually
ahead of the curve.
And if you do
something like that,
then you have a
little bit of room
to maneuver, too,
because as Kathleen said,
often, editors don't get
back to you right away
and then you are in this awkward
position of am I waiting or am
I moving on?
And usually, what I
do if that happens
is I'll send a follow up
saying, if you're interested,
please let me know,
if not, I'm moving on
and then you can move on.
But definitely, if you
can anticipate and get it
in ahead of time, that gives you
both a bit of room to maneuver.
ANN MARIE LIPINSKI: That's
great, great, great advice.
I mean, editors are
always assigning
their reporters
anticipatorily-- is that a word?
And so to think
about that for Op-Eds
is a really good
piece of advice.
You had your hand up.
AUDIENCE: I did?
ANN MARIE LIPINSKI:
Oh, you didn't.
OK.
AUDIENCE: Well, I sort of did.
ANN MARIE LIPINSKI: Sort of did?
AUDIENCE: It was a
follow up to this--
ANN MARIE LIPINSKI:
Jeff, say who you are.
AUDIENCE: Oh, hi.
I'm Jeffrey Zupan.
I'm Naomi's postdoc.
It was a follow up
to that discussion
where I've often
been in a situation
where there's a
timeliness to an issue
and you'd love for it to
have the impact of The Times
or Globe or something like that.
But you have a
Huffington Post blog
and you could just
post it in an hour.
And so there's that
deliberation as to how long--
you say you're not
waiting for us,
but we're waiting for you,
like we'd love to hear back.
So is it appropriate
to literally
give you just five hours
notice or something like that?
I always felt rude putting
such a hard time stamp.
KATHLEEN KINGSBURY: I think it's
really a case by case basis.
If it's something like you want
to respond to claims that there
has been a genocide in x country
and that news has just broke,
then I think giving
editors five hours is fine.
I think if it's something
that is a week from now,
we know this report is going
to be released, give me
a day or two.
And I also think the
other thing I would add
is it's always appropriate to
follow up because there are
often times when I
miss the first email,
but the second email
for some reason--
it's quieter or there's
something happening
and I can get to it faster.
But I would say you're
selling something
when you're trying to put
your opinion out there
and you have every right
to say this offer expires,
I would say.
ANN MARIE LIPINSKI: Yes.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
I'm Melani Cammett from
the Government department
and I have a question
that's sort of related
to the fake news question,
which is are you perceiving
that expertise is
more discredited now
or taken less seriously?
I'm asking for a
particular reason.
I was in a social situation
about six months ago--
and I work on the Middle East, I
specialize in the Middle East--
and I was absolutely shocked
at how many statements
were made that were
completely wrong about Islam
in the Middle East.
So I got it in my head
to write this book aimed
at the general public correcting
some of this misinformation.
And I actually gave
up the idea because I
became convinced
after conversations
with colleagues that
my expertise would not
be taken seriously by precisely
the people I want to target.
And so I've been
sort of wrestling
with whether it's
worth bothering
with this sort of thing
and also whether--
and this relates
to Naomi's point
about where we place our pieces.
If I'm writing something
about how Muslims
do not actually
disproportionately blow
themselves up or
something like that.
Is this better
pitched at an outlet
that's not The New York
Times or The Boston Globe
or something like that so that
I reach a more general audience?
Or is my likelihood of getting
discredited higher elsewhere?
Thank you.
JAMES DAO: That's
a tough question.
KATHLEEN KINGSBURY: I know.
I think you've kind of put
your finger on the larger
existential question that
our industry is really
doing some soul
searching on right now.
I think that if you're placing
something with The Boston
Globe, you sort of
know the audience that
is going to be reading
The Boston Globe
or The New York
Times going into it.
I would love to
say that you should
be broader in your
thinking in terms
of where you're placing things.
I think that one of the issues
we saw in the last election
is the fact that we have seen
the erosion of news outlets,
particularly in the middle
part of the country,
given the financial
circumstances
that our industry finds itself.
That said, you are
opening yourself up.
I actually often feel
like I'm a therapist as
much as anything
when I'm dealing
with particularly new writers.
And I have to
explain, like you're
putting yourself on a page.
We had a piece that a writer,
an academic at Berkeley
wrote for us about
sexual assault
and her own personal
experiences with it.
And I literally had to--
I went back and forth with
her repeatedly about the fact
that she was really putting
her own personal experiences
for the world to read and then
the comments were horrific.
And I felt like we had done
a lot of work to prepare her
for that I just didn't--
that she was very upset.
And so I feel like that that's
the one thing I always say
is make sure you know what
you're getting into, too, when
you're offering your
opinion, particularly
on a controversial subject,
that you know going into it
there are going to be people
who disagree with you.
NAOMI ORESKES: I don't think
you should give up, though.
KATHLEEN KINGSBURY: No, no.
NAOMI ORESKES: I think,
actually, the harder it is,
the more important it is.
Right?
KATHLEEN KINGSBURY: Yeah.
It's a good point.
NAOMI ORESKES: And
I think there are
things you can do
to protect yourself
and maybe we should have
another session for us academics
to talk about how
to protect yourself,
because I'm trying
to figure out how
come my name got taken
off that list of the 40
horrible liberal professors--
anyway, that's another story.
But there are a lot of
people in this country who
want to hear what
you have to say
and the trick is to figure
out how to reach them
and that means working
with your editor
to think about strategies.
And one thing I learned
after my last book
that I'm taking forward
into my next project--
and this gets back to the whole
fly over country problem--
I hate that expression.
But most book editors, like
most newspaper editors,
are very focused on certain
populations in New York,
Boston, Los Angeles,
San Francisco,
people who buy books,
people who buy newspapers,
people who still subscribe to
newspapers, and that's great
and those people are important
and we are those people.
But there are a lot of
other people in other places
who will buy books and read
books if you reach out to them,
but your editor
won't send you them
because your editor's
business model is not
based on Des Moines--
I keep coming back to Iowa.
I was obviously out
of my mind right now.
But you can negotiate
with your editor.
And I learned this in
my last book project
because my editor was
just going to send me
to five big cities,
urban markets,
but people reached out to
me and I went on a book tour
in Kansas.
I went to three
cities in Kansas--
Lawrence, Hays, and Manhattan.
It was one of the best
things I ever did in my life.
And to this day, I
carry with me the woman
I met in Hays, Kansas.
So I went to Hays, Kansas
to talk about climate change
in a very, very, very red place
surrounded by wheat fields
and this woman came up to me
and she said, God bless you
for coming Hays.
So I mean, you can
reach people, but you
have to go to where
they are and there
are strategies to do that.
And I think we could
talk about that
and I'd love to talk more
about that, actually.
ANN MARIE LIPINSKI: Yes.
AUDIENCE: I'm Tyler VanderWeele,
School of Public Health.
I was wondering if any of
you had additional balm
to offer to the
paranoid academic who
would like to keep in all of
the caveats and exceptions.
I recently published an
Op-Ed on protective effects
of religious
participation on health.
And after the editor was done
with my carefully constructed
piece, while I could
see how it was much more
appealing to a general audience,
made me cringe a little bit.
Is this something that
we just kind of need
to deal with and get over or
do you have further advice you
might give to those of
us who find ourselves
in such a position?
IRIS ADLER: I
think you just need
to keep on focusing
on the impact
that you're going to have by
getting your pieces published.
that's the price that you're
paying in spite of the fact
that it might be contrary
to all of your training
and all of your instincts.
And quite frankly,
that's why it's
so hard to work with
academics because they
know they hold and cherish these
sort of rules in their head
about how they
should write and how
they should express
them self very dearly,
and it's understandable.
That's how they've been trained.
But you just have to think
of the greater impact
that you will have by
sort of letting go of that
and just suck it up and do it.
[LAUGHTER]
ANN MARIE LIPINSKI: I want to
be clear to underscore that it's
not an anti-intellectualism
or anything like that
that motivates that
response from journalists.
I spent nine years on
the Pulitzer Prize Board
and for those books,
we spent a lot
of time talking
about the footnotes
because that was very
important to that form.
It's a different form and it
has different conventions.
So one is absolutely
essential for one form
and a different
convention absolutely
essential for building an
audience with the other form.
So you just have to kind
of think of it that way
and let go.
IRIS ADLER: I think
it's also important
that we really have hard
data now, all of us,
on our online
writings and columns.
When did people stop
reading, at what point?
And we have it for
the radio, too.
At what point did they stop
listening to that story?
And it's not that we don't
want to go long and deep as you
might want to, it's
just that we really
understand with very hard
data that people are going
to just stop paying attention.
JAMES DAO: Ann Marie,
can I just say we all
represent opinion
sections so we want
you to have a point of view
and so that point of view
has to be clear and
if it's not, you
publish it in some other place.
But that said, we often
want Op-Eds or long essays,
whichever, to reflect you
know the counter argument
and to the degree
you can explain
what that counter-argument
is concisely
and accurately, it makes for
a better piece, almost always.
Of course, you're
setting it up accurately
so you can knock it down.
But that should be
part-- it doesn't
have to be a part
of every Op-Ed,
but that's often a part of
a very successful Op-Ed.
KATHLEEN KINGSBURY:
Sorry, I'll just
add, the one other thing I
would say is trust your editor,
especially if you're working
with a reputable publication.
You can push back if you
think, for instance, a headline
goes too far or something,
but we do do this for a living
and we do have a sense of
what people are going to read
and what people are
going to respond to.
And so I often get
pushback that how could
I possibly choose to take this
paragraph out, it's essential.
But there is actually thinking
behind why we're doing that.
ANN MARIE LIPINSKI: Does
anyone have a question who
hasn't asked a question first?
No?
OK.
Go ahead.
AUDIENCE: This is
just a quick follow up
to what the gentleman
asked earlier.
So I've had great experiences
with most editors.
On rare occasion, I
come across an editor
who has really taken what
they've gotten from me
and used it to convey a
very different message.
So at what point does my
ownership over those ideas
begin and so on?
And is it appropriate for
me to say, sorry, I don't
want to be a part of this?
JAMES DAO: Yeah, totally.
Absolutely.
KATHLEEN KINGSBURY: Absolutely.
JAMES DAO: We view-- and if this
was a New York Times editor,
you let me know-- we view our
role as helping you to make
your argument, not to make our--
most of us, we're running pieces
regularly that have arguments
that we think are daft or
terrible or wrong headed,
but that's what we do.
That's what the Op-Ed is.
That's the Op in
Op-Ed, to some degree.
So you should always--
it is your piece.
If you don't like where it's
going, then you pull it.
If it's right on deadline.
I may not use you again, but--
I'm kidding.
But we always send playbacks
of the edited versions and very
often people pitch a fit at the
last minute and we try to work
out a compromise,
and if we can't--
it's never happened
under my watch,
but I'm sure there's been cases
where people pull their pieces.
NAOMI ORESKES: I
have to go to class,
but I wanted to just add because
this is so important for you
guys on the supply side.
That does happen and I've
had great experiences
with almost all the
editors I've worked with,
learned a lot from them.
Totally agree like your
editor is an expert
and you should trust
them, but I recently
did have an experience
with a piece that
had gone back and forth,
worked closely with an editor.
I was happy, he was
happy, all good.
And at the 11th hour,
I mean literally,
like 11 o'clock at night on the
night before this was supposed
to run, he came back with a
change that had been suggested
by his boss--
we won't say what
newspaper it was--
and it was unacceptable to me.
And I was actually very shocked
and I said to this editor
who I had a relationship with.
I said you can't be serious.
Actually, to my mind,
completely undermined
in a significant
way what I was doing
and I just said
it's not acceptable.
I said either we get is that
or I'm pulling the piece.
And at that point, you have
leverage because they've
actually made a space.
Not that they don't have other
things they could put in,
of course, I'm sure you
have tons of things.
JAMES DAO: We've learned
our lesson on that.
Yeah.
NAOMI ORESKES: But the point
is it wasn't acceptable
and I just said
it's not acceptable.
And then we went back and
forth a few more times
and came up with a
compromise that was.
So you have leverage,
especially at that last moment
and you shouldn't allow
anything to go forward that--
I mean, stylistic
things are one thing,
but if there's something
substantive that you are not
comfortable with,
you actually have
to stop it because
that's your expertise
and credibility on the line.
ANN MARIE LIPINSKI: And the
last thing an editor wants
is the person who wrote the
piece complaining publicly
about how something was
distorted in their piece.
So it's just in
everybody's interest.
And before we let
Naomi go, there
is one point I
wanted to bring up
that maybe she could
just quickly address
before she goes to class.
And that is I think I've
heard from, in particular,
from junior faculty, that it's
very hard sometimes to think
about and to justify why
they should be spending time
doing this kind of
public work when they're
so busy doing the work they
need to do to achieve tenure
or some other status--
NAOMI ORESKES: Yeah.
ANN MARIE LIPINSKI:
--and focus third time
on academic publishing.
And so I'm wondering
if you could just,
from a point of empathy, just
talk about that for a minute.
What is the value of
doing this work when
you've got so much else to do?
NAOMI ORESKES: Yeah.
That's a hard one
because I never
like to tell other
people what to do
or how to live their lives,
but in terms of the value,
I think that's a good way
of putting the question.
I think there's a
couple of things.
I think this election
really brings
home in a really serious way--
a lot of people are
beating up on themselves
about the election
and different things
they could or should have done.
And all I know is I
sleep well at night
because I know for
the last 15 years,
I've been doing everything
possible that I can
from my vantage
point to communicate
to the American people
about climate change
and why it matters to our lives.
So I sleep well at night
knowing that I've done my part
and that's, for me,
personally gigantic.
And I couldn't justify being
an ivory tower academic
if I didn't personally
have that piece of my life.
So it's just a really
personal thing.
Other people will
feel differently.
On a less personal
note, I think the value
from a sort of
pragmatic standpoint
is that you actually do become
a better writer and better
communicator when you
work with professionals
like these amazing people here.
This is my chance to suck up
to these wonderful people who
have taken the time to
come to be with us today.
Just like you want people
to respect your expertise,
they have expertise.
Like Iris just said, they
have data at their fingertips.
They have experience.
They know a lot
about what works.
And when you work with them,
you learn from their expertise
and you become a better
writer and that carries over
into your teaching
and makes you better
able to reach your students, it
carries over into your pitches
to publishers when you're
shopping those books around
and your publisher
asks, well, who's
going to read this other than
the 17 experts in Sanskrit
irregular verbs?
Right?
You have to make the
case for your work
on all kinds of
different levels--
well, Liz isn't at
Harvard Press anymore,
but when you go to the
editor at Harvard Press.
So being able to make
that pitch to boil it down
to say why somebody should take
the time to read my 800 page
magnum ocean opus on the
history of cold war oceans.
I'm much more able to
sell my academic work
as a result of having
done this more broader--
I don't like to call
popular broader work.
So I think it does make you
better at your job, overall.
That doesn't happen
overnight, but it does happen.
And I know when I work
with my students now,
Jeff will tell you, I'm always
hitting on my students now,
what is the point here?
Why is this important?
Why Should your reader
now spend the next three
days of his or her
life reading this book?
Right?
And that carries over
to everything you do.
So I think that's the
pragmatic value answer.
ANN MARIE LIPINSKI:
That's a great answer.
Thank you very much.
I started by saying it was a
kind of a different time when
Judy first put this together
and a lot has changed
in the months since then.
And the discussion here that
came up a couple of times
about fake news
is really a huge--
not so much development,
because it had been happening,
but a moment and a moment
for all of us to acknowledge.
And trust me, it's rocked our
industry in really significant
ways as well as the tech and
the social industry that is also
grappling with these issues.
But the cure for fake
news is factual news.
The cure for lies is knowledge.
And it is so
incredibly important
that you all think
about what role
you can play in that, at least
it is from my perspective.
And I'm in a completely
share Naomi's view
of the value of that.
So really on behalf
of the democracy,
to thank you all who have so
much knowledge and expertise,
to thank you all for taking
the time to even think
about this issue
and how you might
bring your voice to the
public in a stronger way.
And then, please join
me before we break
and let you talk to them
individually, if you'd like,
please join me in thanking
our three amazing panelists
for their time.
[APPLAUSE]